happy wednesday everyone it is wednesday
am i right
so the democrats are in bad shape how
bad a shape well if they were a person
they'd be this
the latest fox news poll shows the
president drowning on every key issue
he's so underwater the secret service
had to untangle him from a fisherman's
net
so look who they brought in to cheer
everyone up
yeah it was either that or take joe to
chuck e cheese but they were afraid he
might choke on another pepper but it
looked kind of sad
[Music]
just 19 a day and you can save a pet
that was really depressing someone put
on old yeller to cheer me up
he looks like a four-year-old boy who
lost his mommy at the mall
it's kind of worse he looks like jesse
waters at his last class reunion
biden hasn't been that ignored since he
called saudi arabia but i guess when
things are bad you got to make it feel
like the good old days mr president
welcome back to the white house man
feels like the good old days memories
like the time your vice president jill
who is my sister-in-law passed the new
deal and the louisiana purchase all in
one day
so while you're dealing with five dollar
a gallon gas biden's waltzing down
memory lane it's the shortest lane by
the way
meanwhile voter enthusiasm is at its
highest level since 2010
when kat just turned 30.
an nbc poll found a 17-point republican
advantage the last time anybody saw a
gap this large evil knievel tried to
jump it
i wonder what joe thinks
[Music]
oh yeah
sometimes i just like to
ride the amtrak and
pretend it's the old days
[Music]
i'm not kidding
i'm serious
i'm not kidding
it's a true story
hey hey buddy i'm serious about that
it's a true story
it's no
so amazing
so is a blood bath coming for the dams
maybe but let me be a soggy blanket
something i was known for at camp
it's not gonna be a blowout if the
voters don't finally see the true big
lie that democrats care it's a lie we've
been taught since i was a kid like the
tooth fairy and everyone is beautiful
it's what made me a liberal back when i
was just a model for svelt teen monthly
but when it came to compassion
republicans sucked and democrats ruled
the dems cared more about the poor the
sick the downtrodden while republicans
played golf at their all white country
clubs before digging into panda stakes
and endangered spotted owl eggs then
afterwards they'd head to a local
orphanage and beat the crap out of a
redheaded child in a wheelchair
sounds like mitt romney's autobiography
but it's not true and it never was but
it didn't matter because few challenged
the lie and when they did they were so
bad at it republicans would say things
like hey we don't eat panda steaks
they're too gamey or the kid in the
wheelchair didn't have red hair he was
bald
but the next
election can be a game changer if voters
see the truth about democrats that in
power democrats caused a glaring covet
inequality between the masks and the
masked knots the marginalization of
parents even calling them terrorists an
epidemic of homelessness fueled by
untreated mental illness and drug
addiction a crime wave that's turned
cities into chaotic hellholes with that
list every single democrat should lose
because all those problems are part of
the liberal wheelhouse a wheelhouse
greased by you the taxpayer it's what
they claim to care about
the children the sick victims rights
education but in reality it's just about
power because in every single area i
just mentioned life has gotten worse
under democrats yet they've been given
more second chances than criminals who
randomly attack people it's the one true
red pill for all voters every place
where the left claims the higher ground
has left americans dead or broke
coincidentally those are democrats most
reliable voting blocs
look at the new mayor of new york city
so much promise
but so much
he's taking over a city plagued by so
many problems that liberals are supposed
to solve the mental illness the
homelessness poor education and what
does the mayor do he trashes florida and
pleads for gays to move back
but mayor what good is a pride parade if
you're walking on syringes maybe clean
the subways before you start inviting
people over you're putting a welcome mat
in front of a house on fire
and with kids he's no better he just
decided to extend the school mask
mandate for children under five which is
anti-science and anti-kid and he did
this after he exempt exempted athletes
and performers from the covid19 vaccine
mandate so it's one set of rules for
kids and another for the stars i guess
he knows parents of school children are
easy easier to push around than lebron
james or jay-z
and besides who wants a selfie with a
three-year-old and a mask he's not even
famous
so no wonder a new poll finds that 59
percent of new yorkers believe their
family would have a better future if
they quote left new york city
permanently
that's one solution leave go to texas
tennessee even florida yeah mayor have
you been to fort lauderdale lately it
makes san francisco look like green bay
new york city better add a tax for
people trying to move
but soon we're just going to run out of
places to move too that's why this
election matters all elections matter
including school boards it's no longer
just cities that are in trouble it's a
country so maybe it's time instead of
moving out we move them out and show
them how compassion gets done the right
way
let's welcome tonight's guest she's
proved the pens mightier than the sword
by using it to stab an editor at
buzzfeed editor chief of the federalists
and fox news contributor molly hemingway
you've seen him at america's top comedy
clubs validating your parking writer and
comedian joe devito
she's like a streetlight skinny bright
and attracts a lot of bugs
foxy's contributor cat too
[Applause]
and his baby carriage was an 18-wheeler
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion
tyrus
molly welcome back to the show good to
see you
always a pleasure to read your work
why does everyone still assume it's the
democrats who get compassion why do we
still believe that
is that going to change ever yeah i mean
it's kind of never been true but they've
done a very good job they control the
corporate media and the corporate media
does a very good job of helping them
with um with all of their messaging but
i just don't see how you can live
through the current moment and think
that they are compassionate toward
anyone much less the working class
you're looking at all these problems
throughout cities in america all
controlled by democrats and things are
extremely bad so it is definitely time
for that reputation to change yeah if if
it were republicans
and you had this homeless problem drug
addiction problem crime problem
the media would actually try to solve it
right
no i think they might be so evil that
they wouldn't try to solve it yeah but i
have very low yeah for them me too you
know joe uh did you feel sad
watching
the other joe big time with the music i
expect to see sarah mclaughlin spinning
him around you could rescue this poor
it was so sad to see
uh how he was overshadowed by obama it
was like imagine if you went to a star
trek convention and people are saying do
you want a picture with captain kirk or
well here's klingon number five you can
get a photo with him well he's supposed
to be the guy who's in charge so
it was not good to see that it's it's
it's humiliating not just for him but
for the united states yeah in the
contrast the contrast was quite sad it's
like when you know somebody says oh
here's greg gutfeld look at him and oh
there's tom brady and then tom brady
just looks so pathetic yeah yeah
it's brutal yeah
did that flash through your head no it's
that did you put me up against tom brady
and go wow i have to say that's not what
flash through my hand
it's like okay like if you used to be
really close with somebody and then like
something happens and you're not anymore
and then you have to like see them out
somewhere and they just treat you with
this like sort of polite indifference
it is so painful you got to like play it
cool and then just like listen to dreams
by fleetwood mac on the way home
but
i checked instagram yeah and joe follows
barack but barack does not follow joe
oh my god i know it keeps getting worse
it really is bad did you see it when joe
tapped obama on the shoulder and jo
obama didn't even bother to turn around
yeah i know
biden's hand is so frail he probably
didn't even feel it i don't know am i
standing under the air conditioner what
is that
it was like the finger tap of death
brutal yes you know um tyrus i
do you okay here's here's
did they believe bringing uh
obama back would be the kind of a
a thing that brought the democrats some
energy and then it backfired or did they
want to do this on purpose
you know that's a really good question
you know that was
painful to watch
because he the only thing he didn't do
was close his eyes when he reached out
he was reaching for people if you look
he was kind of like this he looked like
where is his wife just or like one
friend or one
security guy i i have been in those
situations as a bodyguard where a guy
has grossly overpaid for my services and
is not that popular and he's in the room
with celebrities standing there and i
will go he's got three seconds before i
walk and be like you got a call sir big
thing i got jay-z on line two he doesn't
do about his lyrics and people look
around and i did something like wow who
is that guy wow who is that guy yes and
saved the moment and of course asked for
a raise afterwards nobody was coming to
save him and it looked even
kamala had people she was it was obama
her they had the little group and then
he was like
this is where he could have took a page
for the previous administration because
if that would have happened on president
trump's one he would have stepped in the
middle of him excuse me yes what is all
this going on here about in fact he did
do that yeah he did that he did the
thing like don't stand in front of me
but he would have had a moment he would
like i'm president brock you induced me
you know but he didn't do that he looked
he looked senile and frail yeah we
that's the thing
we make jest but that looking at that is
a senile frail lost man and that's the
leader of our country right now but
wasn't it revealing too you know you
hear all these people complain on the
right about joe biden but that was the
first time you actually saw a bunch of
democrats and what they think they don't
think joe biden is president they do
think barack obama is running things you
might explain i told you they were going
to stab him in the back progressive just
needed him to get in yeah now he's used
up his usefulness and now they're going
to if i was there i would have let him
smell my hair yeah
i feel so bad watching that i'm nice i
would ask for
you know i would have chatted him up he
would have you know he might have had a
weird kind of odor but that's okay or
like lied like yo trump's online too he
said he'll fight you in the backyard
right now let's do it come on joe let's
do it give him a moment something yeah
funny thing is so you probably go and do
that and then he'd blow you off right
just like you're not important
accomplished and i would ask for a raise
there you go hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else